Hello, welcome, everyone.
My name's Matias Duarte, and I'm
here to tell you a little bit
about Material now--
right here, right now.
So happy birthday, Material.
It's kind of a cheat.
We haven't actually
reached a full year.
We're one month
shy, but it's still
a pretty amazing milestone,
a pretty exciting milestone.
Last year at I/O, we
introduced Material Design.
We wanted to make a system
for designing across platforms
and across screen sizes.
We wanted to combine the
best of modern graphic design
with the real utility and
usability of surfaces.
And most of all,
we wanted to create
a system that put motion
at the heart of design
and didn't slap it on
as an afterthought.
And, believe it or
not, when we did this,
and we brought it to
you all last year,
we didn't actually know
how it would be received.
We were a little nervous.
And it turns out, we actually
got some love for it.
Right on the first
day, we started
seeing some pretty nice quotes.
The tech press was able
to see and understand
what Material was about.
Developers started
responding immediately
with real appreciation for
what Material was about.
And, of course, most
importantly, designers
seemed to really
understand what we
were trying to do
with Material-- trying
to create a system that
would help and support them
in the challenges that
they have designing
for all the interactive
platforms that we have.
So, phew, like, yeah, we could
all leave the I/O keynote,
go to the bar, have
a drink, relax.
So this made us
feel really good,
at least maybe, for
that first week.
But the real question
that we have,
and I'm sure a question that
a lot of you have as well,
is, how useful is Material?
And because we're
Google, we like numbers,
so we're going to take a look at
Material Design by the numbers
to start off this session.
Let's start looking
at our guidelines,
the Material Design guidelines,
what we affectionately call
the 'spec.' Over the last year,
a little less than a year,
it had 2.5 million
unique visitors.
I think that's pretty good.
I mean, maybe if you're
a YouTube celebrity,
or you're doing cat
videos, that's not so good.
But for a design guideline, we
thought that was pretty good.
In fact, even more importantly
that that, more than half
of you, in fact, over 60% of
you are returning visitors.
And that means Material
Design wasn't just
something you checked out
once, but it was actually
a recurring, useful reference.
And we see tremendous
activity in the color section,
in the typography section,
in the iconography section,
and, of course, in the
component section, like the FAB
and other specifications
like that.
So not just designers
seem to be getting
some use out of Material,
but developers as well.
If we look at Polymer, which
is Google's system for bringing
Material components
to the web, we
see that developers have
looked at Polymer's paper
elements also 2 and
1/2 million times--
the specifications for how to
use Polymer paper elements.
And more importantly than how
many times they've actually
referenced these is
how many paper elements
are actually integrated
into products,
which has been 100,000
paper elements out there
on the web, which is really
good for a framework that
wasn't even out of beta
until Jason announced it
this morning.
Now, of course,
you're all wondering
about Android--
Material on Android.
Now, it has been pretty exciting
to see Material apps come out
on Android.
And if we look at
them by the numbers,
we see nearly a quarter
million material apps
in the Play Store, apps that
are taking advantage of Material
Design by either targeting
Lollipop or using
appcompat libraries.
Now, maybe that number doesn't
seem big enough for you.
Your thinking, oh,
my gosh, there's
like a billion Android
devices out there,
or how many did
gajillion Android
apps have been in the Play
Store over the last seven years.
But if we put that
number in perspective,
and we think about Lollipop
being released in October
of last year, and we look at
how many new apps, new Android
apps, entered the Play Store
since Lollipop was released,
we see that the materialized
apps account for more than 40%
of those apps.
More than 40% of the new
apps in the Play Store
are materialized.
And when you think
about how many of those
apps happen to be
games, that number
starts looking really good.
That means that basically more
than one in three new apps
are taking advantage
of Material.
Yeah, you can applaud for that.
That's OK.
No, it is actually a
really exciting start.
But we want to make
that number even bigger.
Design is never
done, so we're going
to spend a little
bit of time now
talking about how we can
make those numbers bigger,
how we can make those
numbers grow faster,
how we can make it easier for
all of you to bring Material
into your apps and
into your designs.
We've been continuously updating
the Material Design guidelines
to be better and
more comprehensive
since we launched.
And since we launched it,
we've updated the guidelines
two times already.
The first time, in
November of last year,
we gave you all sorts of new
sections on organizing objects,
navigation drawers,
scrolling techniques,
as well as swipe to
refresh product icons.
In April, we gave you
another update, more guidance
around app structured,
data tables.
We give you writing
guidelines for Material,
a whole bunch of other things.
Today, we're giving you the
biggest update to the Material
guidelines since
we launched them--
a whole bunch of new stuff.
So it includes refinements
to design patterns that you
know and love, like the FAB.
Turns out, a lot of you
really liked using the FAB.
When we launched the spec, we
only provided limited guidance
on how you could use
the floating action
button and the different
ways it could transform.
But many of you thought that
the FAB could be more flexible
and that you could use it
to trigger a whole bunch
of new things, and we agree.
So today, we've expanded
the number of patterns
at the FAB supports
and trying to give you
a little bit more
flexibility in how
you can integrate the floating
action button into your apps.
Since so many of you are
visiting the guidelines
for help with icons, we
decided to invest in a brand
new dedicated resource for that.
So today, we're
expanding the spec
to include the
Material Icon Library.
This site basically contains
750 icons, more than 750 icons,
for you to use in your projects,
in an easily organized way
that you can browse through and
that you can search through,
and that gives you one click
easy downloads for icons,
for integration
into your projects.
App developers can
just find exactly what
you need in all the
screen resolutions and all
the densities that
you need in one place.
More than that,
for web developers,
we're actually releasing all
of the icons as a web font.
Yeah, it's very cool, and
it has a super cool feature
that makes it very
easy to integrate icons
whereby using the ligature's
features of modern type
systems, you're actually
able to type the icon name
and have it ligature
itself into the icon.
If you're a type
geek, you'll think
this is the coolest thing ever.
We have a whole talk tomorrow
about Material Design icons--
Material Design Icons
Made Easy at 10:30 AM,
if you want to learn more
about how to use the site,
how to use the font, all
the extra fun stuff there.
Now, one of your biggest
requests about Material Design
was help in adapting designs
and layouts to different screen
sizes.
So today, we're adding
a major new section
to the guidelines
specifically focused
on adapting Material layouts.
We're providing
detailed guidance
on break points between layouts,
a scalable consistent grid,
surface behaviors
and relationships
across those break points.
So these adaptive guidelines and
examples, these new patterns,
are going to help you
create apps that gracefully
adapt to any context.
We have a talk on
understanding the details
of these new patterns,
also tomorrow
at 9:00 AM and later at 1:30
PM, if the party tonight
is a little too good for you.
Now, combined with these new
patterns for adaptive design,
we're releasing another section
of the site-- a device metrics
reference.
Now, this reference
is going to help
you get all the
types of information
you might want for designing
for arbitrary devices,
whether they're wearables,
whether they're phones,
whether they're tablets,
whether they're laptops.
You're going to be able to
get key dimensions, densities,
and all those other metrics.
But, most importantly,
this reference
helps you understand for the
screen size is that you're
interested in how
to plug those values
in to the adaptive templates.
This means you're going
to be able to understand
which template and which
pattern in these new adaptive
templates you should be
using for which devices,
which orientation.
These two resources
together are going
to take all of the uncertainty
that you have right now out
of creating layouts that scale
across different screen sizes
and orientations.
And we hope it'll be really,
really useful for you.
Well, you guys kept asking
for it, so I hope you like it.
And, of course, there's
a lot more updates
in the guidelines themselves.
We have a new
section on describing
motion in meaningful
ways, sections
on launch screens, empty
states, and a ton more updates
and refinements.
Now, as Material
Design has evolved,
more and more
products across Google
are also implementing the
guidelines into their systems
and platforms.
So today, we're also
releasing new guidelines
that specifically
target television, auto,
and VR in the form
of Google Cardboard.
We have a talk on
designing for VR tomorrow
at 11 AM and a talk on
Designing for Driving
tomorrow at 12:30 that'll dive
deeper into these guidelines.
Together, all of this really
makes it our biggest update
to material Design, the
specification, the guideline,
the system that
helps you design.
We hope you'll like
that, and we hope
you'll continue to
give us feedback,
so we can continue to give you
even more updates in the months
and years to come.
We wanted to do something
a little more though.
We wanted to go beyond
just guidelines, tools,
and references that
are perhaps static,
dry, authoritative,
fixed in those ways.
So today, we've refreshed the
official Google Design site
to be a place where our
designers can connect directly
with the community of
designers and developers.
We want to have a place where
we can share why we're thinking
about things the way
that we're thinking,
how we go about designing,
a place where we can host
practical articles, for example,
articles and videos addressing
common concerns for designers
and developers that are working
in Material, like, "How Can I
Go Material Without Losing My
Brand Identity?"
This article's gone live
today, and we have a talk
also complementing it tomorrow
on Expressing Your Brand
Material, also at 12:30.
Or articles with tips
on designing easily
between different platforms,
whether you're starting on iOS
or starting on Android
or starting on the web,
we want you to be comfortable
using Material everywhere.
And, of course, more tutorials
and, what I personally
enjoy the most, some
behind-the-scenes videos,
footage, and lots
more things like that.
So I hope you'll check that
out, and I hope that will also
be useful for you.
Now, all these things
are great for designers
when you're thinking
about what you
want to express in Material.
But the other thing
you kept asking us for
was more help in actually
implementing material.
And since this is a
developer conference,
you know it seems
like a good time
to talk about what we've
done there as well.
So, of course, we want
to start with Polymer.
Last year we announced Polymer,
and, as we've said today,
as Jason announced
today, Polymer
has gone into 1.0 out
of developer preview,
out of beta today.
What that means is that Polymer
is far more performant, far
more stable, and has a
fixed set of APIs now.
And Polymer has
really been scoped
across all modern web
platforms, including
modern mobile platforms.
So if you're designing
with Polymer,
you're building
with Polymer, you
have something that can
really scale to all the places
that the web wants to go.
They tell me that
they've rewritten
every single line of code
in Polymer for speed,
and it is blazing fast.
And what this means,
if you're using
Material Design with Polymer,
is that all of those Material
paper elements that
you've been using so far,
they are now ready
for production,
letting you build high quality
app-like experiences anywhere
on the web.
In addition to that, there's
a new Polymer starter kit
and a catalog that is going
to allow you to learn and play
with all of these
new paper elements
another Polymer elements
before you even get started
building a materialized app.
It includes demos, samples,
very easy browsing,
and what they tell me is
a really cool shopping
cart so that you can just
download Polymer paper
elements without having
to open your command line.
Of course, on Android,
Material is available in L,
and you will notice it is
faster and more battery
efficient in the M
developer preview.
But there are two
things that you're all
asking for out of
Material and Android;
you want more
turn-key components,
and you want backwards
compatibility.
So the Support Library
family has always
been our traditional answer
to backwards compatibility.
It's a plug-and-play
system that makes
it possible to
implement features
from the newer
versions of Android
into apps deployed
on older versions.
And when we launched
Material last year,
we gave your appcompat
library, which
gave you some basic layout
support for Material
and some basic styling.
Today, we're introducing
a new library
in the Support Library family,
the Android design Library.
And this library enables
you to take both the core
elements of Material Design
to these previous versions
of Android, and,
most importantly,
it gives you really turn-key
encapsulated implementations
of all of the major
Material Design elements
that you've been asking for.
So let's look at some
of those elements.
Before, even though the
FAB was a relatively simple
implementation, you still
have to stitch together
maybe five or six XML files.
Today, you can just add a single
floating action button tag,
and you're done.
The new library includes
an easy off-the-shelf card
implementation with
shadows, side navigation,
which we know is
very complicated
to implement with all
the details in the spec.
Now you can just drop in a
Navigation Drawer view and all
of the details,
metrics, behaviors
are taken care of for you.
You Just put your Drawer items
in a menu tag, and that's it;
you're ready to go.
Similarly, we're
making it just as easy
to build Material
tabs into your app.
And one of my favorites is
the toolbar scrolling, also
a very complex nuanced
interactive spec,
and, today, every aspect
of the scrolling spec
is now baked into one component,
and you can just simply specify
which behaviors you want--
the pinning, the collapsing,
the scrolling offscreen.
It's all there.
We introduced Palette last year.
Palette is fantastic
for really integrating
your content and your apps.
Today, we're giving you
an upgrade to Palette,
making it six times faster.
And these are just some of
the highlights of the Material
capabilities that you get.
Check out the developer
site for more details.
And, as I mentioned before,
Support Lib doesn't just
get you complete
material components that
are easier to deploy, it lets
you deploy material to more
Android devices.
Today, Lollipop represents
only 10% of Android devices.
By using these newly released
Material components in Support
Lib, you can now
bring all of them
all the way back to Android 2.1.
You can lose your
shit over that one.
That's worth it.
So we want to help
you embrace Material,
and we want to evolve Material
in response to your needs.
And material doesn't just evolve
through the things that we do,
but in the concert and
conversation with you.
So over the last year
we've also launched
a number of different programs
to help keep us connected
and have this dialogue happen.
And I want to highlight
a couple of those today.
For starters, we've
launched a program
that we call Design
Sprints at Google.
These are full-day
workshops in our design
space called The Garage
on Mountain View campus.
And we bring companies and teams
of designers, program managers,
and engineers together to
tackle specific problems
in their product
development, helping them
not just with the
materialization of their app,
but with any aspect
of their app design.
This has been just
a fantastic resource
for teaching and reaching out,
but also really understanding
what are the problems that
your teams are facing as you're
building applications.
And it's been a really intense
process, but the response to it
has been absolutely fantastic.
And, as you saw on
the previous slide,
we've engaged with 17
companies, and we're
continuing to do that.
It's been really,
really worthwhile.
In addition to that, we've run
over 100 design reviews, which
are smaller, one- to two-hour
focused sessions, where we have
some of our designers
meet with some
of the designers on
your teams, walking
through specific aspects of
implementing Material Design.
Again, this has just
been an amazing way
to help us stay connected as
we help you implement Material
Design both from a technical
and a design standpoint.
Now, I was going to advertise
the fact that we're doing many
Designer . views here at I/O all
day today and all day tomorrow
in the Design Sandbox.
But they tell me these are
actually sold out already.
So if you've already booked
yourself for one of them,
don't miss your time
window, or it'll
be given away to somebody else.
And if you couldn't make
it to those Designer Views,
please do reach out
to design@google.com.
Both the Design Spring program
and the Designer View programs
are really an important
part of the process for us.
They're something
we want to give
to the community as a service.
We really want you all to
take advantage of them.
And, of course, in addition
to the Designer Views
that we're doing here at
I/O, since you probably
can't make it to them
if you haven't already
booked for them, we
do have a full slate
of Design Talks all
day tomorrow as well.
Once again, showing
that design has
become really
important to Google
not just for our products,
but for our outreach
and our connection to you.
Please, please come
check them out.
Last, but certainly
not least, last year,
we hosted Google's first
design conference in Fort Mason
here in San Francisco.
Let's take a quick look at
the video recap of that event.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC LUKE VIBERT, "WE HEAR
YOU"]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
That was an amazing event.
I don't know how many of you
have a chance to go to it,
but it was an
incredible opportunity
to connect to the
design community,
and we had visitors from
all over the planet,
actually, brought into the
San Francisco for that.
We had talks.
We have panels.
We had hands-on workshops,
and we're planning an encore.
So please stay tuned for
plans on what the next Form
conference will look like.
So, at the end of the
day, Material Design
is really just a
means to an end.
The reason we did
this is because we
want to help you create more
beautiful, more immersive, more
intuitive experiences for your
users, for your customers.
So it's only fitting that
we close out this session,
and we shift now to take
some time to talk about some
of the amazing things that
you've all done with Material
over the last year.
We had a chance to talk to a
number of the companies that
have gone through this
process of going Material
and hear their stories.
So now we'd like to share
a few details about some
of their experiences.
First up, is Trello,
a productivity app
that helps you organize
and share various projects.
And you can see Hamid here
found that the process
of materializing Trello
was useful in really
focusing the product itself
and focusing the design.
Material served
as a filter, which
they found engaging
and satisfying for how
their app should evolve.
But more than that, they also
saw some pretty significant
impact to some of the metrics
that they really cared about.
That's the kind of
thing we like to see.
Let's look at The Hunt, which is
an app that helps you discover
and share fashion styles.
Again, Jenny really
appreciated how
Material was like
an augmentation
to the design team,
not something that
was in conflict or contrast
to the design expression
that they wanted to have,
but something that helped
accelerate them.
And that also really
makes you feel good.
That's exactly what
we were aiming for.
And likewise, The
Hunt team told us
that they had some impact--
some material impact,
pun intended-- as a result
of the materialization
of their app.
Finally, Pocket Casts,
podcast aggregator,
was similarly excited
about how Material
helped evolve their brand,
their look and feel,
really made their app beautiful,
and for them, a 30% increase
in sales.
And that's fantastic.
So stories like this are
a testament to why we made
Material.
This is exactly what
we're going for.
We're trying to help accelerate
and focus and add to the things
that you are already
trying to do.
And if any of you are
trying to maybe weigh
the trade offs between the
investment in going Material
or not, or trying to convince
other people about the benefits
of going Material,
we hope stories
like this are useful
to you as well.
In fact, there's more stories
than we could possibly
tell at this point in time.
But we've been so
excited about the work
that we've seen coming out
of all these developers
over the last year
that we decided
to do something a little more to
share some of these highlights
with a slightly larger audience.
It was very hard,
but we've worked
with the Play team
and the Dev team
to select 18 of the most
outstanding Material apps
we've seen and create a
special showcase collection,
and we'd would like to share
that with you right now.
So let's look at this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Those are beautiful.
It's amazing to see that we can
create a demo reel like this,
like the one we showed at
I/O last year, but instead
of having it be full
of fake conceptual apps
that we just dreamed
up as examples
for how you could use Material,
now it's full of real apps
that you have brought to
life, embracing Material.
And it's super, super
exciting to see that.
So today, we're creating and
releasing this Material Design
showcase on the Play
Store to highlight
some of these amazing apps.
So additionally, we
want to recognize
some specific
executions of Material
that we thought
were particularly
excellent or noteworthy.
So we created a
Material Design award.
And this year we
decided to give it out
to six different categories.
And we'd like to
right now, today,
publicly acknowledge these
particular Material Design
pioneers.
They're all actually
sitting here in front,
so I'd like ask them to
stand up right now and get
us a round of applause, please.
Thank you.
The whole team and myself
personally are just so
thrilled to see you actually
bring Material Design to life,
because a system by
itself is just an idea.
It requires your hard work, your
dedication, your innovation,
your creativity,
the extra sparks
that you bring to your
implementations of Material
that make it actually real
and make it actually tangible.
So thank you again.
Oh, wrong slide-- backwards.
So, in summary, we're
just absolutely thrilled
by the success of Material
in this first year.
We want to keep
talking to you all.
We want to see and learn
more from you all about what
is working, what isn't working,
what more you'd like to see,
what crazy ideas and
innovations you build on top of,
which ways you push a
new twist the system,
and you break the system,
and you do all the things
that real innovators,
designers, and developers do.
I'm really looking forward
to another fantastic
year of Material, working
together and seeing
where it goes from here.
I hope we'll be here
together again next I/O
to celebrate Material's
second birthday,
but so far it's been a
fantastic first year,
and there's lots more
exciting stuff to come.
So thank you, again,
all for coming here.
I hear that drinks are
going to be served next,
so I don't want to
keep you waiting
any longer than I have to.
But let's raise a toast
to Material's first year
and Material's
first birthday when
we get together at the party.
Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]